et à votre avis tient votre annick qui
s'était passé pour un millionnaire pour
séduire à jean michel michel mr non jlg
bien dansez maintenant
cette tabac là on vous croira pas à part
peut-être paris s'il tonne
merci madame
alors oui le soleil tape fort sur
l'hippodrome de chantilly n'en peut plus
oui alors nous sommes en 1995 est un ami
de la très haute société très riche m'a
invité à un mariage avec que des gens
riches
d'accord j'ai ondes y aller avec ma
petite voiture et donc je ne sais pas ce
qui me passe dans la tête je loue une
voiture de luxe pour trois jours à
l'époque c'est quoi comme voitures dites
nous la marche jeudi la marque maserati
ola ray comme j'avais une maserati
ah ouais donc on va citer d'autres
marques de luxe lada voilà dans heroes
heroes nous on adore il en faut trois il
en faut treize d'entre eux bredouilles
ils ont été très bons 3000 francs vont
soit bien encore 450 euros je loue sa
mais oui je vais un mariage et donc
j'arrive avec ma petite voiture au
mariage on me met côté vacances voiture
à côté d'une jeune femme magnifique
oui donc les gens commencent à dire des
donc une maserati dernier modèle du bois
oui c'est de la famille etc et je sais
pas pourquoi je m'enfonce dans mon
mensonge
la jeune femme parle de voiture je parle
de voiture je dis je vais vous ramener
chez vous mademoiselle etc
je la ramène chez elle et on donne
rendez vous pour la semaine d'après je
m'en faire toute la semaine et je dis
c'est pas possible je ne m'en plus j'y
vais avec ma modeste voiture que j'avais
ma belle clio ouais donc j'arrive pour
venir la chercher
à ce moment là elle dit mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette voiture je dis je
suis désolé c'est ma vraie voiture ans
et elle m'a plaquée en rentrant chez
elle elle la vie doit c'est mon vrai
pointe au 30 juin
[Applaudissements]
elle m'a largué là et elle a bien eu
raison non pas parce que j'avais changé
de voiture mais parce que j'avais montré
qu'ils étaient intéressés ça m avait
l'alluré sombre à cause d'actes manqués
bien et à côté de vous ce soir